des rencontres entre des employeurs et
des jeunes organisé par le réseau
départemental information jeunesse ce
forum jobs d'été a réuni près de 25
recruteurs dans la salle des fêtes de
bois d'arcy
c'est vrai que c'est un pas vers
l'autonomie c'est à dire leur première
expérience professionnelle que kippel
vagues qui peuvent valoriser sur leur cv
et puis pour certains c'est aussi
financièrement pouvoir financer leur
permis pouvoir financer leurs vacances
d'autres projets ces postes saisonniers
sont accessibles dès l'âge de 16 ans ce
type de forum est toujours un rendez
vous très attendu par les jeunes
travailleurs le chercheur pour gagner
l'argent et les idées reçues
j'ai quasiment trois mois de vacances
vous faut savoir dépasser à rien faire
en fait et cet été je vais devenir
majeur donc partir en vacances sans ses
parents il faut automatiquement de
l'argent différents secteurs d'activité
étaient représentées parmi les
recruteurs de la grande distribution des
enseignes de commerce d'hôtellerie
restauration et la mairie de bois d'arcy
nous cherchons un poste en voirie donc
pour les services techniques nous
recherchons quatre quatre jeunes pour le
mois de juillet quatre jeunes pour le
mois d'août la voir il c'est autant pour
les filles que pour les garçons il faut
juste être volontaire et courageux
prochain rendez vous pour les jeunes à
la recherche d'un job d'été le 15 mai à
chanteloup les vignes